now so here you are you're hanging out
in Minneapolis you're meeting all the
bands the movies taking place in your
head how long did it take you to write
your your version of the script what I
did was I interviewed for about four
weeks and then I started what I was
doing I was in to interviewing during
the day and then writing from like 11
o'clock at night to 7:00 in the morning
and in those days I wasn't writing on a
typewriter
there was no computers obviously I was
writing longhand with a ruler and I
would just write the whole script and
then a secretary would get up at 7:00
and type it and then I'd go back out and
do interviews so it was what I had
described to Bob which is an organic
approach understanding the scenery
understanding the people understanding
the music and then writing from the
heart and I felt that if we were
authentic we would have a shot if we
weren't authentic we wouldn't show so
what and let me jump into when when he
interviewed us it was real I mean he sat
there and listened to us he found out
what our beats were found out what our
characters were how we dealt with each
other that's why it came across soul so
natural as first time actors and he
captured that and you know I used that
same theory now when I write did you
have to want to have any casting
suggestions for you guys well that's
just that's a story I wanted to I don't
remember what happened is we went in
myself Bob Steve and Joe and the first
thing they were this is the lineup mark
and what was the head of the studio at
the time very similar yeah but not not
them that they had a production anyway
there was one other individual in there
and then there was three women who were
developing pretty cool and they said we
read the script and it's the most sexist
misogynistic script we've ever read
this is a disgusting portrait it's
disgusting the way you're treating women
that dumpster scene is absolutely the
worst thing we've ever read they just
they just you know and and the
interesting thing I was looking at
Markin because I thought it was gonna
like him and he was in a sense turning
red because he didn't expect the
velocity of that hatred and I they said
so what are you gonna do about it and I
said I'm not going to do anything about
because here's what's important this is
the scenery this is just seen there this
is authentic and we're not going to
change anything because it will not be
an authentic movie so then they said
thank you and then they said well we
have a few casting ideas we think that
it would be good to have John Travolta
play Prince
that's the more ridiculous given so how
did Prince do it so anyway they said
what do you think about that idea and I
said I don't like that idea
Prince has to play Prince because that's
part of the authenticity that I was
talking about a moment ago so meeting
went very bad from that point on